une maison francs services a ouvert ses
portes à mantes la ville située à 100
mètres de la place du marché à côté du
service d'action sociale du département
mais surtout à proximité des quartiers
politique de la ville un emplacement
stratégique le but pallier les
difficultés d'accès aux services ses
missions accueillir informer et orienter
les usagers de pouvoir accompagner donc
les usagers vers
les services qui sont en ligne et nous
aider donc allé à les remplir il ya
également une notion administratif donc
c'est des démarches tout les aider à
faire les démarches administratives
également donc en physique et donc la
plus grande des démarches d'orienter
donc les usagers vers les opérateurs
neuf opérateurs sont partenaires de la
maison offrant ce service le ministère
de l'intérieur la direction générale des
finances publiques le ministère de la
justice la cpam la cn avait la caf pôle
emploi la msa et la poste le but
accompagner les administrés dans leurs
démarches administratives par exemple
faire sa déclaration d'impôts en ligne
ou encore débloquer ces indemnités
objectif créer un lien entre les
services de l'état et ceux de la commune
pour faire leur carte d'identité il faut
se créer un compte à mts à partir de là
on les a réorienté vers france services
pour que nos agents puisse les
accompagner a créé ce compte là c'était
surtout des personnes âgées qu'on pas
l'habitude d'utiliser l'outil numérique
donc là on s'est posé avec eux on a
travaillé avec eux on leur a montré
comment créer un compte nts et à partir
de là ils ont pu retourner en mairie
pour déposer le récépissé de carte
d'identité sur place un bureau de
confidentialité pour participer à des
visioconférences des bureaux de
permanence pour les services partenaires
et une salle multimédia beaucoup de
démarches maintenant ce fonds
en dématérialisé et donc
certains voire beaucoup nos administrés
ne sont pas en comment dire en capacité
de faire ses démarches au sun donc
l'idée c'est vraiment qu'il puisse avoir
cet espace qui leur est dédié avec des
agents qui les accompagnent pour toutes
ces démarches administratives
depuis l'ouverture de la structure à
mantes-la-ville déjà 900 administrés
sont venus profiter des services